growing up in Oregon was the plan to get
into film boy you know so when I grew up
yeah I mean I fell in love with film at
a very early age but you know and every
filmmaker you know had the story oh my
dad gave me a camera when I was a fetus
and I was told my own birth or whatever
that was not me I my mother is very
religious and movies were considered
evil and tools of the devil I was am
still told that Hollywood is the lion's
den and this is where I will lose my
soul so there was that my dad was a
machinist you know salt of the earth you
know you know an engineer kind of person
and like he just didn't understand it so
like there was no one in my life that
knew this but I just wanted it so bad
I'll never forget the day when I was at
the beach with my dad and I look over
and a grip truck pulls up no I'm young I
don't know how young I was big young
young enough but I recognize what it was
I saw that back door open up in his full
of sea stands and sandbags and lights
and I swear my feet left the ground and
I just wanted to like go to it like I
didn't I don't know what they were doing
over there but it looked like magic and
my dad just looks at me like you really
want to be over there don't you like you
know he was sort of smirking and smiling
you know not in a negative way but but
whatever the case I was denied this like
you there was no access I had like
before I could drive I wasn't given the
camera the only thing I had was a tape
recorder so I would record my stories on
he was for the audio and I ended up
writing a novel when I was in grade
school because I just had no access to
anything it wasn't until I got my
driver's license when I could go to the
public cable access station and borrow
their camera that was how I first got
into it I don't know if they still do
that but that's a wonderful resource it
was for me at that time but I didn't
know I never had a mentor I didn't know
what to do I didn't know anyone who did
this for a living I went to school and
majored in communications which didn't
help me at all really but they didn't I
didn't even know about film festivals
I didn't
in LA I was terrified of the big cities
and of course I got the weight of that's
the lion's den weighing over me so I
didn't know what to do and I when I got
out of college I didn't know about
internships I didn't understand how to
do that so I got out of school I worked
a dead-end job for two years and I was
so depressed because I wasn't even on
the ladder to get to where I wanted to
go I had one friend that I knew in
Nashville Tennessee and he said well you
know your are a musician and you like
film so there's a lot of that here you
could try a - film like I'll do anything
so I moved there without knowing even
knowing my roommates move oh wow then
they go and even when I got there though
I still had the same problem like I
didn't know anyone I didn't know what to
do I
I worked waiting tables at the Olive
Garden at night leaving my days open so
I could in turn somewhere but no one
wanted me and I had to and again there
was no plan I just I was desperate to do
anything - yeah just let me look at the
work being made I don't care
and that's what I ended up telling
people you don't need to give me a job
just let me watch the work being made I
don't just let me be in the room when
it's happening and eventually one guy
said okay you can watch me work this it
sounds so creepy but it does that's
exactly how it started and and so that
sort of was okay this plan is working
I'll try that so I went that way and
finally after a few weeks he said all
right I got a shoot next week you know
when I come help I could pay a 50 bucks
a day get great great I'll do it for
free even I don't care get to set it was
five days of shooting we worked excuse
me 20 hours a day my knees were swollen
by the end of the week because there was
very small crew and like I said 50 bucks
a day and it was the time of my life
like I finally got somewhere but the
plan was I didn't know like and that's
the thing if anyone tells you they they
know how to make it they're they're
lying because there is no way this isn't
like being a doctor or a lawyer if you
want to be those things that path is
clear you
to school for this many years you go to
do your residency you interned Edyta go
back to school you know there is a very
defined path there is no path for
filmmaking you anyway you can get there
you have to go
that means snatching onto every
opportunity you've got the media as soon
as you find something that it looks like
it might be a way through so that's how
it has been for me like you know Oh an
opportunity to work on a film as a PA I
don't care I'll do it like yes I mean
that has worked out to be very very much
in my favor like even things like fan
films for example I'm directing a fan
film right now that most people kind of
poopoo the idea of fan films which is
kind of crazy to me because fan films is
interesting when you think about doing a
short film right if you're trying to
practice your craft well when you get it
done you gotta talk someone into
watching it because what good is it if
no one sees your work right you can get
into festivals and when you play a
festival more than likely as a short
you'll be crammed into a block of shorts
and most of the people in the audience
and this is not being cynical here this
is real reality when you get shoved into
a block of shorts most people in the
audience are the other filmmakers who
made those other shorts so it's it's
just a smattering of other people like
they're only there wait watch their
their work right you have a term for it
I think it's a something sandwich okay
it's probably not safe for work I fast
yeah anyway yeah they're they're all
that so anyway you got okay people watch
your film and it's really hard to do get
also yeah you gonna watch my short it's
about this time traveler who went back
in time when he meets his grandfather or
whatever right okay if I have 15 minutes
how long is it that's 25 mil man I gotta
find 25 minutes to watch your film or
you make a fan film and they yeah I made
it I'm making a fan film about Splinter
Cell I love Splinter Cell you made a fan
feeling over that too I want to check it
out it's so the name of the game you got
remember is to get people to see what
you're doing whether you're an actor or
a cinematographer director it doesn't
matter writer you have to get people to
see your work and what's the shortest
way to get that to done you got to look
at that's where the opportunities come
in and fan films have been great for me
and for other filmmakers I mean look at
the guy who directed 10 Cloverfield Lane
made a fan film about the video game
portal that got him boom got him down
the road there's a guy I've heard who's
working on a big franchise film who made
a fan film for bumblebee that got him
into some doors like there's many many
many stories about people who did that
and then they got to another level it's
gotten me into rooms making fan films
and that's what I mean by the
opportunity like at first you know if
you judge it be careful take a serious
look at what opportunity this might be
and snatch onto it grab your way forward
it's it's how I've made my whole living
and made my life so even though
Hollywood maybe was considered like you
know the the Gateway to bad things I see
though that like the work ethic is what
is what propelled you so even though it
was forbidden you still have that work
ethic in you yeah yeah it's a good
combination yeah and you know you're in
an industry where there is all kinds of
unscrupulous people like this ya ask
anyone they've had some sort of bad
experience with film and getting screwed
over by anyone so when you work with
integrity that means a lot this is why
people when you watch it like Martin
Scorsese for example he always hires the
same people Sam that's because integrity
can be rare so when you find the people
that are integrity and talented you hang
on to them with everything you've got
and you fight to get them on all your
projects because you know that they're
good people that will deliver yeah
that's that's really valuable that's
better than any demo reel that's better
than your fancy website integrity people
knowing that you're gonna do what you
say you will do
bring it on time that's very important
and and you know read any business book
they'll tell you the same thing
you